good morning Lani else today's the best
day of my life because it's just it just
is because Kevin McHale and Jenna
Ushkowitz are here obviously you know
them from Glee but now their fellow
podcast host so as we always say fellow
podcast host must support other fellow
podcast shows so we're really excited to
have you guys here you have a new show
called showmance great name for a show
it's on the lady gang podcast network is
that correct yes and it's just like
another Glee moment it's a little bit
about your show how does it feel to be
podcast host taking it you know off
screen to now behind the scenes I got a
camera on a microphone tell me about it
it feels good for a number of reasons I
love it yeah Jenna's done podcast before
so I was like if Jenna wants to do it
I'll do anything she wants to do and we
get to spend more time with one another
yeah that's always a bonus
I mean Becca was like do you guys want
to do a podcast and we were like yeah we
didn't even come by the concept we were
just like yeah we want to work together
yeah so now we get to talk to Glee folk
and other fokin you know gap because we
like to your own voices and you guys
have had some internet me to us on the
show if I'm correct you all about the
dynamic duo
so you add tea radomir odd yes sound
like I live for them it's Brad Goreski
and Tanya rod in case you like live
under a rock I actually know who they
are but I didn't know the people do I
know them but you know they call them
tear out of me I call themselves to
write it I I love them I
we know Brad but I never met Tanya
before and she is one of a kind
angel from God there's no so good I just
said across in Mike you guys talk a lot
of times now after we've met so many
amazing duo's I just feel like that
awful person in high school like let me
be your third wheel happens in podcast
and I go show you're like we're so
similar and then there's like sometimes
real friendships form and then this is a
great way to make friends
Hey we thought of speed-dating because a
lot of times people will come in right
let's not talk yet and then you
immediately get into like really deep
and intimate conversations yeah
our like oh we now know each other
normally this takes weeks or months of
being friends or somebody to get to this
level of bonding this yeah so you're
letting hi knows yeah so you guys met
obviously on the set of Glee
yeah and that's also where you met Becca
and just obviously like you don't
understand like I'm really sorry to be
annoying but like this is that saved my
life because we were just telling you
how we saw you guys in concert at Nassau
Coliseum like we were true Gleeks like
and I still am I watch it all the time
on Netflix you guys see that no I I
passed by and I realized it was in the
gay section yeah I forced my boyfriend
to I was like come on I'm gonna show ya
and then I realized like halfway through
one of the musical performance I was
like this is really awful and tacky
you should probably forget with me I'm
gonna stop now but just one more
performance okay but this makes me think
of this one so I'm gonna do that and
then I had people over that night and
then we turned on like the Apple TV
business and then there was live and
like who was watching this well I could
just say your recovery is remarkable
because you can walk thank you honestly
like I'm sure that this happens to all
the time but like I up until like follow
me on Instagram like five years ago I
thought for sure that you were in a
wheelchair everybody that's what it is
we could do that should not be doing
well you know we talk about all the time
on this show is how Glee was like so
transformative and it was almost like
before it's time like clean really seems
like a show that would exist now but
like when I was in high school in a new
era like it was the first wave of
Michael Musical shows but also seeing
all different types of characters on TV
and like having that experience as as a
child yeah it is sort of feel like the
looking back now the link between what's
before and what's happening yeah the
euphoria's of the world yeah it was sort
of like that to get to where we are now
we've got a lot of questions for you
guys from Instagram like people were not
well
including myself well and this is
actually such a great question cuz like
okay I do this but maybe I'm just saying
is there a song that you guys covered on
the show that you will hear now and like
you still another choreography oh yeah
last name we did obviously I didn't even
dance it dance but I learned the caucus
you danced it for me like recently I was
like I don't know why it automatically
comes out of my go and here we go I
don't remember what I didn't it I can
hear somebody for sure oh that was the
choreography for that too I do that with
the background vocals too that it will
come on automatically just start seeing
the Glee background it's so lucky I
don't actually exist and it's really
appreciate it then they don't deserve
the performance okay this is actually a
hilarious question from Casey Matthews
how the hell did McKinley High not have
fun funding for a bus with a wheelchair
lift with songs and like full lighting
every time a loophole in the story oh we
talked about awful and it's like okay
maybe like one less show tune a week and
you can afford the bus the amount of
like wardrobe to that like our kid like
the Tina came out and we're supposed to
leave like Rachel's dad put that outfit
to Kurt you tell a sweater highlight
Gina did all the costumes
that is ridiculous I just live for like
you know the behind-the-scenes moments
like just tell me like just so I can
like you know move on with my life like
tell me just like one little thing like
just like a little secret like
logistical thing about Glee like I know
that's super vague okay well here's one
it's not kind of like when you got here
you saw that the sign was actually in
front of us I just like I wouldn't ever
want to know um super Glee days were
this isn't that I'll give you time to
think okay like every day's work you'd
go to get in the makeup chair you would
go just like rehearse a scene you could
rehearsal then you go shoot the scene
and then you go at lunch the recording
studio put down the song or iTunes come
back yeah and then cuz we recorded to
our voices not like demos so we did all
of our stuff before and then you go to
like a fitting and then you go finish
the scene again and then you go to dance
rehearsal now it's like a slope super
blatant that's crazy I forgot then you
guys were like all over iTunes we still
hold like some of the records for like I
know it's new the songs were popular
before but like not with my generation
like I learned the song fat bottomed
girls from Glee I think yes they're not
song yeah I mean is the musical theater
songs from our show it was educational
yeah okay Mackenzie shrug we didn't
update about your current relationships
with fellow cast members we go to
people's weddings we go see people's
babies because last week because so old
what I'm like that's not uni she's like
it is I mean she's a grown woman she's
she's like no we're just old well that's
like Heather was two kids you're like oh
my hero has two kids you can't
like you just grew this baby Kevin you
released an EP yes I did and it's gotten
rave reviews it's great can you tell me
what it's like to be in a recording
studio recording your own music and
bursts like that bottom girls I'm so
used to we recorded hundreds of songs
obviously for Glee and so going in I was
like well I need you to like we had a
such a system where the people were
recording us I'm like I need you to yell
at me like if I'm sucking just I do not
coddle me well certainly we're going in
to do that my stuff I was like yell at
me what what am i doing I can should I
wrap it should this be a country song
because we're so used to like doing all
these new genres of music like what is
my identity anymore I don't know what we
can do but because I think I've we had
like stress or somebody asked me the
question the other day what was the song
that we did better than the original and
I said never going back again
I don't okay you know about him girls
obviously I can't stop referencing it
all so when Rachel Taylor talk coming
back to me now obviously not better than
slate oh really up there it was great
yeah and that's also how they learned
that song and also the Barbra
Streisand's I'm like oakarina great
what's how can we do better
they were very few that I just like oh
actually when your true colors for
columns was actually like the first time
I heard that song very good my husband
like
that song something that looks like I
like it too because you really make me
like it the same that I had never
actually heard that song it's kind of
lame so yes I do like our version of we
did that girls just want to have fun
that I like that was really slow yeah no
it was great also the like mashups
sunshine here yeah I really like needle
I have a chronic neck injury from that
what kind of injuries were sustained
onset I need a desk I have a proper like
a permanent back problems in the
wheelchair oh yeah your tailbone two
people got injured I'm actually oh yeah
Chris got injured rollerskating oh my
god I feel like the florida tune yeah is
the worst i was a challenge always a
challenge um I would say probably the
most questions we got for you guys are
people literally just meet like Jenna I
saw you at Cheesecake Factory and came
up to you to remember me like people
really feel like they're a part of the
ensemble because it was like on four on
TV for so long we were all like the same
age we're all like in high school yeah
does that happen all the time yeah in
waves it comes in waves yeah especially
like when we go international and that's
what happens we're together yes yes is
that like oh that's her so yes it's them
oh yeah I do like now because like you
said we were young when the show was on
and I feel like people who watched it
were around our age and so now people
are sort of calm when they come up like
not like us No thank you think oh you're
just like cool about it you're like oh
yeah I love that like oh I love that
show Thanks I'm sure the tour meeting
rates were live ya know we didn't have
to wear me we don't know we didn't know
how dare you forget I remember you what
was it like being on tour you guys were
flowing into like so many different
opportunities because of the show like
I'm sure when you were auditioning for
the show
you didn't know you were gonna be on
tour like doing stadiums he's better
about the tour cuz he was into music
first but like I wish we had done it at
a separate time when we weren't between
seasons because I definitely want to
appreciate it right well like I slept
through the door yeah like I wish I
could do it again it was like a
bittersweet sort of thing I was like oh
this is an incredible insane opportunity
but you said we didn't think we'd get to
do right by the scene him everyone was
just we're doing our first live podcast
tomorrow tickets still available yes
where can the datatex
search show man's dance come see it yeah
and it's like we're doing a
meet-and-greet again and I feel like I'm
having like it's so nice we're gonna cry
I think it was a great no probably just
start doing all the choreography I want
to be you guys opinion on something okay
great
I don't know if you guys heard maybe
like a year ago a certain conspiracy
theory and I would just love to hear
what your thoughts are on it because
there was like a really legitimate like
worldwide conspiracy theory that Lea
Michele can't read I can't hide anything
I didn't know which goods are so cheap
rooted in conspiracy theories or cast
yeah but I just I wanted to know have
you ever seen Lea Michele Reiter yes
yeah well podcast I'm sorry I'm
forgetting the name and they just like
I've been really like harping on this
idea up finding videos and they they're
the whole presentation and it was very
hard she said yeah you have videos have
heard doing like book signings whether
she like wasn't really writing and like
all her Instagram captions are emojis
and there's no proof out there that she
actually can the best thing
that's observers yeah in today's world
there's a lot of conspiracy why are you
to bow to your pet or Duncan Duncan girl
can read if she can read she can write
did she come back with anything she was
on watch what happens live and they
asked her about it and she thei read was
that Ryan Murphy was like in on it with
her like constantly just like but they
were together so much because he knows
her be a deep dark secret she can't
yeah obviously you've made a lot of
sense when it was presented to me I'm
just saying go rehearse the scene would
she have her sizes heard she already no
no she already knew it makes you think
that's what they were saying that she
just memorize no it's just living to
think about next time you see her yeah
Tim you're enthralling just know I saw
her read books
she reads yes I know which one
yeah I was the pizza guy that they
locked me in an opposite which is great
great episode yeah a lot of the time
though if I can speak for you please
we'll go somewhere and let me think oh
my god you're the kid from the office so
not the kid from Glee they kept anything
off it you're the pizza guy from the
offense well it's arguably just as big
of a show but you did want one episodes
I'm shocked that it still happens that's
crazy you can tell when they're
rerunning it because it sort of that's
like what I'm gonna say it's the dress
it's like did you really do it I didn't
really do it and they play it now like
once every month like in different
countries no yeah cuz I get mean tweets
like this girl's so annoying
oh did you get to do what you wanted on
it yo and they made me okay you know
what they did
honestly it's just my cross to bear but
like they put me on an episode I was
just like all I wanted was a
long-sleeved dress like as if that's
like such a crazy thing you know there
make it seem like its own but then the
other bride she was a bride who like
lost her home and flaws so like they
gave her a whole new wedding like a
house and like I was just like the
obnoxious girl one of the lungs right
like they really just tried to pay me in
a negative light really and so I just
thought it was really worried yeah yeah
like is it so much to ask for a lobster
I love Roxy wedding yeah one criteria to
dress like oh this girl's so diva is so
sorry that she'll be armed Manila okay I
promise I'll stop it's just the
implications of Glee like they never
stop like now out here like Brad Falchuk
and gwennyth are married by now and you
guys like to saw that blossoming
relationship was onset we'd see Brad
come around and when he wasn't directing
and like if you're not directing like
you're not around we would be like yeah
and they were like buddies for a long
time anyway before any of this and like
I don't really know what it actually but
it but like yeah but you know I I was
like I don't know what's happening here
but that's crazy she's also an HTP it's
so cute I think he's he's the best
they just make so much personality as
makes a car sentence together where
they're both just really calm and cool
big deal and so just like bloom on a
beach with no me I know it's like that
was my last question but I just thought
of something that's great you guys were
with the project yeah I was thinking
about that yeah I was on now I would
have auditioned to be on a project not
representing he might have made it I
might be it's funny cuz like we have the
Glee Project we all mentored on it and I
was I was like I don't know what this
show is but like we got Alex Newell from
yeah he was like money eaten from yes
Sam Sam Lindsay Pearce who appeared like
Jenna I leave Jenna yeah that's right
Damian McGinty oh that's
we have money winner Ali stroker
obviously you know Tony winner - yes yes
is creating yeah for what producing high
produce one don't play that down okay
mister self-deprecating Tony we're going
it's on my weird this weird ledge in my
house that actually is perfect for our
Awards so Tony Awards on there yeah I
spin it on my way there like that and
I'm like okay I can't sit here for six
hours and ask us questions like
especially about the mark sailing of it
all but I won't because I thought that's
next time we go yeah you know what this
has been such a happy day and I just
marked sailing we ran it again so thank
you guys for being here tune into
showmance on podcast one the lady gang
Network you can find on itunes about if
I'm sure all the places I haven't heard
it yet but I have a feeling it's gonna
be really good yeah I think we do the
past five with us that's great okay um
and you gonna follow you guys on
Instagram to thirst it out Jenna
Ushkowitz Kevin McHale they're stewing
it live show tonight tomorrow in New
York Sophie or New York stain head over
there I'm sorry come see them we will
take a quick break and we'll be back
you
welcome batter to lineage in that's what
you missed on taste oh wait we just like
take him in this truck right now that
was like the best interview of my life
like I loved that they weren't some
people like when they do press like they
never want to talk about like the thing
that like made them famous and they were
both just like so cool and open and
willing to talk directly as much as I
was and I really just like I stand hi
Stan and they really made me miss Lee I
think I might have to re-watch it's such
a you know I forgot to ask them I once
asked what their thoughts on the ending
were how did it end I don't remember but
like not well yeah a guy tracked out a
little bit but no shows like they ran
like Tina's character into the ground
you know they didn't do her justice no
Tina was like never getting justice no
she was like the opposite of justice
yeah it all worked out for everyone well
thank you for joining us this morning
out of special early time so me and
Margo can make our show in Virginia
Beach tonight tickets available Carlton
job calm so without further ado if it's
all right with everyone I do believe oh
it's not all right there's so much to
disguise I'm sorry like I don't even
know but top of mind for me it's the
snatcher episode that premiered new
episode of the snatchler dropped this
morning head over to iTunes and Spotify
uh it was a great episode it was a great
episode we were sweating bullets oh my
god I didn't stop talking doing podcasts
not in a studio when we do it at our
house we have to turn the air
conditioning off is some of my least
favorite times of my life yeah it was
tough but I really felt like I got
everything off my chest it really like a
weight lifted it's like and it's nice to
not carried now into the next day that's
actually very true like every time like
I have an episode to record of any
podcast I've so many thoughts like I
don't want to forget them so I'm
constantly thinking about them and then
just kind of like vomiting it out felt
really good yeah it's like I don't know
why he'd starve a bit on the show this
week I talk about duty but it's like
every single message I've been like I
can go to bed now and it's just stuff
like so peacefully that's me it's like I
got so much done yesterday I sleep
knowing the snatchler has been recorded
yeah and is scheduled at 8 o'clock so I
don't have to wake up
yes yeah yes today was such a busy day
like literally didn't stop moving
today's the same I'm not gonna stop
until I'm in my hotel room in Richmond
tonight not
in Virginia Beach so much drama you know
life on the road man
cowabunga you sound like I know I love
John Paul Jones yeah you want some
Chinese did you see someone putting the
toasters that they finally figured out
to jump off Jones looks Landon Landon
Clements for ya Shh other drummer if you
want to know all of our thoughts on back
to our paradise we won't get to them
today on this year's show because we
gave them all to the snatcher she's
right there I'm right here
we gave the snatcher everything we have
to offer and more everything we have to
offer we took all of your guys's
feedback I don't know if we listened to
it but we heard it no but we tried we
tried we tried rests we're constantly
working on not talking over each other
it's just a constant battle but if you
like the snatcher we would love and
appreciate if you gave it five stars on
iTunes wrote a nice review and you know
just take two minutes out of your day
yeah I got a lot for the toast - you
like what you like while you're there
yeah you know you made the journey the
Schmitz there's a bunch of new episodes
of the Schmitz - tons of content to get
you through this treacherous slow-moving
workweek and speaking of the shit's I'll
be joined by Ben tomorrow to do this
here show and I'm gonna say that because
it's been a while since we had that Kido
maniac on the morning toast
Hido maniac [ __ ] um should we have this
love island kids tomorrow I think
they're available yes right you know I
forgot to DM her just let me let me uh
Alex and Dylan from Long Island they
were supposed to come on yesterday but
it took so long to get approval you know
all the drama with television actually
so many questions for her about the show
so hopefully they can come through it's
lit man Oh Alex Stewart it's not
verified okay there'll be found like
couples you know yeah except you bet on
a couple but you know I mean totally
like dynamic duo's right it's like show
it's not a cool concept for a podcast I
thought it interesting it is are there
so many dynamic duo's out there but not
they're not exclusive to dynamic to us
but they like having guests with to
people that are like like Brad and trad
like just friends you know what I mean
they don't like us like work together
but just two people who are like
well-known friends well-known friends
very cool I want to see who else they've
had on idea they're gonna have on
because that is interesante
speaking of interest and here are the
Fast Five story is that you need to know
before you wake up and take a bite out
of your
burning toast and will you do me a favor
just so I don't like cry brokenhearted
devastated will you please just let me
tell everyone the same episode is
brought to you I don't know why should I
let her the morning toast is brought to
you by MTV's the real world Atlanta
streaming now on Facebook watch the
original reality show is back and
streaming now only on Facebook watch
MTV's the real the real world Atlanta is
the next true story of seven strangers
picked to live in a house and have their
hookups screw-ups apologies fights tears
voices and lives streamed exclusively on
Facebook watch it's the return of the
first unscripted show in TV history that
tackled gender race AIDS taboo life
death addiction connection acceptance
and reality and it's being reinvented
MTV's the real world Atlanta is an all
new reality experience with content
dropping daily and new episodes every
Thursday that's tomorrow find out what
happens when the next generation stops
being polite and starts getting real
again in facebook click on the facebook
watch icon and search the real world on
watch MTV's the real world Atlanta
streaming now only on Facebook watch and
a new episode drops tomorrow love it
love it okay here we go
in today's I say we go new is that the
song that plays first on your when you
plug in your phone I don't plug in my
phone anywhere
eh Oh mine is the a-team I don't plug my
phone in its first few chords of the
a-team like now irritate me they're
supposed to be super serene but it's
like shut the [ __ ] up ed sheeran yeah
Marga what's the first song that plays
on your phone ooh all mine by Kanye West
that's weird
yeah you don't have a Oh or the a-team I
don't know for some reason well now in
this day and age it's like we don't have
songs on iTunes family buy songs I need
to like put them in a video on YouTube
so I still somehow have the a-team on my
phone that's so crazy let's see what my
first song is would be finesse I don't
[ __ ] know yeah well if your first song
is guess yeah no that can't be right
anyways back to the news of the day what
do i okay continuing our updates in the
Jeffrey Epstein murder mystery or is he
a mystery it was Sir glug we came in the
with a knife well some new news is has
come out recently two interesting
factoids said I want to share with the
group as I'm gonna take it upon
ourselves to be the leading source for
the real news about what's going on with
Jeffrey Epstein who is still alive and
living in the jungles of Cambodia right
first up apparently the news of Jeffrey
Epstein's death was on 4chan like 45
minutes I heard were it was on its first
news source which is a DC so like
someone they think a first responder
like leaks to the information on 4chan
4chan is the most evil place again i SD
NY said it did not come from one of its
members so like who did it come from
well so we're just supposed to believe
the FDNY I'd like yeah of course like
they have their firefighters like code
yeah and I don't see firefighters on
4chan like that just doesn't I don't
know let's write like in the station all
day you got to find ways to occupy your
time I know that's why they should be
listening to the morning to us and then
thinking about subgroups so we have any
firefighter toasters for sure we have
toasters who do everything we should
film a video like a patreon of us going
through firefighter training you know
how hard it is like can you do those
mock classes yeah he where the get him
on The Bachelor and you run up a set of
stairs like I would probably go into
cardiac arrest we should do that
Sen why the toaster in the FDNY I have
to believe one exists just one just one
member when we met like the first and
only female FDNY mmm-hmm I wonder if
she's still the only female that was
like five years ago she is amazing she
was amazing she was so heroic she was
and so inspiring yeah we met her at a
conference regina flinch um anyway he
says I think she sneaked back to a that
is I heard another interesting fact item
what is it Stacy jail okay yeah okay so
this is what's crazy because now in the
investigation into the death it has come
out that the guards in charge of
watching over Jeffrey Epstein had
reportedly fallen asleep and hadn't
checked on him for three hours then
falsified records to cover up their
mistake those guards have been placed on
leave while the warden warden of the
Manhattan jail has been reassigned also
someone who was recounting their time
when they switch shifts this a guard
spoke anonymously in the New York Times
and said that when he switched shifts
the new guard came in he didn't
recognize him he said what's your name
he said Steve
and he was like what's your last name
and he was like [ __ ] he's like okay
fellow Jitsu Joe that's like literally
from the dictator employees must wash
hands yes
Alison's burgers when you look around
jail no but like what a janky job but
like the Clintons or whoever it was it
it like hiring someone who couldn't even
think like Steve Cohen like literally
any lesson Steve black like literally
anything nope
Steve jail Steve David and it's just all
of this is adding up to me that there
that it was not a suicide at the very
least also people heard shrieking from
his cell so I mean when you hang
yourself like you can asphyxiate you
like choke could you like would you be
screaming or someone murdering you um I
don't think you could actually be
screaming I think you would only be
choking and like gasping if hanging if
being murdered obviously I think you can
scream yeah so maybe this the shrieking
makes me think that maybe he wasn't um
escaped you know that seems like the
harder thing to pull off but I'm going
murder Oh interesting yeah cuz I guess
if he wasn't escaped you would know go
silently he'd be like okay let's go
galine but maybe he didn't know that it
was a plot like someone in the outside
was doing for him and he thought he was
actually being murdered when in reality
he was just being taken back to his
Island yeah but then they had to get the
body double in there and now that they
have to talk to the like mortician and
like they have to pay off everyone
whereas if they just murder him like
it's over or so they think
but now this guy bar the Attorney
General he will not let this go but like
oh good yeah I mean it's good but you
blue you have your chance and you blew
it
cisgender state in the words of my
brother district in the words of my good
dear friend Giamatti it's just a little
too late yeah you had your chance Paul
Giamatti for millions yeah the Southern
District if this show is like another
one to be controversial but it's awful
what do you mean it's amazing plans do
you watch I watched four episodes on it
do you know what I prefer billions by
Russell Dickerson breaking it in by the
bill yeah we see that I love Russell
dickerson that song is awful
Jackie it's a good song it's it's not my
kind
it's not my kind of country okay anyways
so that's your daily update into the
life and death of Jeffrey Epstein or
alleged death yeah still no more news
has come out and nothing no candy bar
wrappers found on the island yet no DNA
oh but a computer was found there they
got his computer and I just feel like
Jeffrey Epstein and Sir Gregor Clegane
we're like not the types of people just
likely paper trails on computers that
they left on random Islands yeah like
this pedophilia ring has been going on
and been organized for years like they
are smarter than leaving a laptop you
know but everything that they were doing
was so out in the open you know like
they literally were doing it on an
island with like Google surveillance
coming down and they were they were like
recruiting girls not even in underground
ways just like going to country clubs
going to high schools going to massage
parlors and just like doing everything
like kind of above ground that maybe
they they didn't even feel a need to
hide bikers here so above the law yeah
and here's my other question when you
own an island technically is that like
your own country like can't you make
your own laws where you can [ __ ]
underage girls that's a good question
really not because you think
islands are aren't they like territories
of countries yes but like what could
what would have stopped him from being
like I want to secede no that's not
that's a very interesting call and I
want to make my own laws because they're
still without their that have laws that
that America probably when installer
know it's like the drinking age like you
can go to gear up and drink when you're
18 but I think if you're coercing women
from America to your Island regardless
of if your Island has that law it's
still illegal okay yeah that makes sense
like you're taking underage across state
law and like cross country lines
island lines it's like when America when
an American is murdered like in another
country then like writer comes in I
don't I I think the laws of the US did
apply to his Island but I wonder why he
didn't secede from the union I don't
think this is according to some of the
comments I don't think you can make her
own laws but Islands can fall under
various territories in which you
probably have to follow those laws got
it and I guess in no country like is it
okay
have sex slaves and you know kidnapped
girls there has to be one yeah like a
lawless country there there's probably
I'd like to apologize to the podcast
viewers I accidentally got some ice in
my mouth and I'm going to chew it so
nice done well we will keep you updated
in the neverending saga of what the [ __ ]
happened to Jeffrey Epstein but
hopefully we'll get a crack in the case
you know yeah I think if anyone can do
it the toasters can yeah so true
honestly if the toasters were on this
case when the FBI was like this this
would be a done deal
yeah okay next story close back to some
celeb news which is new for us these
things Harry Styles won't play Prince
Eric in live-action Little Mermaid
apparently he was offered the role
rumors were swirling that he got the
part but apparently he turned down weird
I mean I feel like I don't know what
Harry Styles is trying to do with his
career because he released his solo
album you're like okay he wants to be
like the Justin Timberlake but he didn't
release another album then he did that
awesome war movie what was it called
John Kirk John Kirk which was awful but
it was like highly respected and and it
was like a huge thing for him so he was
like now he's an oscar-winning actor and
you would think he would want to take
the role of Little Mermaid maybe it's
not serious enough for him but it's like
still such a huge production it's gonna
have so many eyeballs and it's so many
like really well respected people Queen
Latifah like I don't know III don't know
what his motives are me neither I think
I don't think he cares about like the
fame and the big career and taking parts
that are like you know in big
blockbuster movies because he's probably
had plenty an opportunity or he could
get the band back together and they
could be doing that um for me personally
like I would like to just I would like
to see him go down like a Zac Efron
route career-wise where it's like you
can be a respected actor but also do the
things that like people are gonna love
you for and I think him not taking this
Prince Eric role is a mistake like in
order to be he could be the next backup
right because I'm sitting as Prince Eric
but I don't think he wants to be like I
think he wants to be like this indie you
know under the radar guy he doesn't want
to be like street heartthrob yeah I
think so too you just he Luigi Tomlinson
did it everywhere he was like I don't
know when but we are most certainly
going about
back together we will be together oh I
didn't feel like he was like 100% like
no matter where we are like we it is in
our plans I I hope so and I think we all
kind of knew that cuz they they always
did say it was like a brain hiatus um
also I know all these guys really want
to be respected musicians and you know
they like to do their own thing and put
out music that they can be proud of but
like one Direction's music is so [ __ ]
good no I hate that they're regarded as
like a silly boy band know teenagers I
usually only they regard themselves as
that like everyone else is like no these
are [ __ ] beggars and maybe if you
like took out like this synthesizer you
know you can make it more musically
whatever yeah but and when I'm in a long
car ride like I will most definitely
just put on shuffle all by the one
direction discography like it is good
[ __ ] jams I went to Melek Stadium and
saw them like probably their biggest
sounds like what makes you beautiful
okay I understand they don't trash in a
trash whatever but like when you get
into like album four and all of these
songs they're I actually think the album
without saying was one of their better
ones um I completely agree yeah look I
didn't even feel the loss of Zayn the
way that like the Directioners did you
know no I agree I mean there's some you
and I like they really have so many like
actually like musically good songs yeah
and but they have one terrible song that
I hope that never little things little
things many talks about her love handles
I just want to die yeah like that is not
feminism no it's just it was so weird
yeah I'm sorry it's okay anyways I don't
know what his plan is but I hope he has
one maybe had to reject it because it
was conflicting with the plans to bring
back one direction that is something I
can see and would definitely hope for so
since I guess the Internet is casting
the Little Mermaid
who do you see for the role of Prince
Erik what do you think about Jacob Oh
lordie well he doesn't sing okay no it's
like everyone sings in Hollywood because
they're all like theater nerds you know
yeah okay it's like a hot dude who can
sing oh my god but he's not an actor but
that would be great what is acting great
it's just he's acting right now in his
relationship totally good job okay Shawn
Mendes would be good who sings like a
who's like a young Zac Efron it would be
someone from
like the guy who played Link Larkin from
teen beach movie Ross Lynch no oh but he
would be good it would be good but hold
on I think his name was Greg not Sulkin
teen Gregg Sulkin would be good can he
sing I don't know but he's huh my god he
would be great he looks like Prince and
I feel like he could sing I feel like he
could do it all
this guy's maybe like if you weren't a
part of the Disney machine like you do
have to be able to sing all right
Clayton and I'll show you a picture
honestly he would be great
Cupid do a great job as Lynn Clark and I
felt I have absolutely Oh Eric doesn't
sing according to the comments so we
don't need someone who sings I just need
someone handsome Oh Gregg Sulkin great
silk'n right how old is Hallie Bailey
organized me an age appropriate age
appropriate Gregg's 26 no I'm trying to
think of like maybe someone else but
Kylie Bailey is in since when does
Hollywood care about appropriate she's
[Music]
fired by Rudy fired
she's 19 she's 19 yeah that works for
them honestly I really like the Gregg
Sulkin call yeah I just hope Michelle
would be okay with that you know I think
she would be she's so supportive in like
you know she's I don't think I could
handle dating an actor I like seeing
them kiss people like I would get so
insecure
I would I would die like I would die and
then I would like literally every time I
get to UM like you started yet staking a
CD test I don't understand how they do
it that's so I guess like Hollywood has
to have these you know more than you the
one who told me that the guy from
Desperate Housewives
like who played Dave Dave EES crazy
husband doesn't care he won't kiss other
women he won't take roles where he has
to be like be in bed with a woman yeah
or where he has to kiss a woman but and
I think everyone like regarded that is
weird at the time but later it's not
weird like I guess it's weird because
that you shouldn't be in that industry
but like I can't imagine being married
and like either one of us acting no I
would die I had like a fun way they like
express herself sexually and then like
also be married you know I mean you're
like if you're an actor there's no
reason for you to cheat wait you're do
it for free like yeah no problem so
strings
touch yeah yeah maybe we should get into
acting yeah I think so
who is that picture what is the next
story oh that's not the neck story but
it's jay-z oh wait some big news today
you did he's partnering with the NFL to
help them with entertainment and just
like but it's not a story
getting Morales it is oh yeah but we'll
get there okay people were suggesting
Noah Santini up or the role yeah he's a
little messy to be a prince he's a
little messy looking he's a little
floppy haired yeah he's like a little
too much like curl in his hair to be
like a slick back king of the ocean
I completely agree and I don't think he
wants to slicked back his hair no also
like like he's getting a Messier like in
my first met him on that movie I was
like okay I could see it but like after
following a minute Instagram and like
just having him be famous for a few
years like he is not Prince material no
he's not he's just like that sloppy ER
and floppier you know it's just like the
hair gets longer and curlier yeah and
like we need to tap him for the Gossip
Girl reboot so you play dad no they're
gonna play new characters but I just
feel like that's what preppy kids look
like these days but they're like mess of
hair yeah but like he should really be
dead like that hair is so good they're
bringing back the old characters they're
not missing new one I think and I think
there's a character from Brooklyn it
should be Noah Centennial they're
choosing me ones it's not a there anyone
who lives in Brooklyn I don't know that
was young that far but probably I mean
Noah Noah I'm not a main snitch
kashubian I actually I'm pretty sure Ben
Ben Schwartz said that I don't think
there's like anything there's no bigger
honor than like as a teenager as a
teenage girl like being selected to get
cast in the Gossip Girl reboot like it's
a great opportunity but at the very base
like it's flattering it's [ __ ] you know
yeah I think you're cool enough and
pretty enough so I be like the elite New
Yorker you know yeah yeah I love that me
jealous
cast maybe is like someone's mom
someone's big says someone's add some
honeys and smooches okay I'll take it
okay next story um some news that's
making it it's circling the drain some
news that's making news bebe Rexha oh I
saw that and you know I was said we
didn't talk about it so yeah yesterday
we were just inundated with stories so
um the b-team
about today yeah the lower the stories I
didn't make it
bebe Rexha slams male exec who said she
was too old to be sexy pop star bebe
Rexha blasted a male movie executive who
said the 29 year old daughter artist was
too old to be posing for sexy photos by
posting a selfie wearing nothing but a
bra and the thong who died recently had
a caps male music executive tell me that
I was getting too old and that my brand
was confusing because I'm a songwriter
and I post sexy pics on my Instagram and
that's not what female songwriters are
supposed to do especially for my age she
wrote on Instagram Monday I actually
totally feel it's because I was told
yesterday that I'm too old for something
and I told it by my own sisters sister I
didn't but Margaret read yes yeah but
there's something talking about my age
no I discuss a woman they oh my god all
we were saying was that man Lerner both
worked with this Amazon event last night
it was a back to school like showcase it
was like for college students and I'm I
did a performance like about college and
I just didn't want you to feel bad so I
just like it was all the influencers
were college-age like you probably just
weren't invited because you're too old
and that hurts thank you and that's
better I I don't know like I almost wish
you had been like no they just think
you're ugly and fat and then have you
Belliveau and you're so it's garbage
they didn't want to be associated no I
just think you were okay how about this
you all turned out of the age range
hurts um baby Rex I see you we see each
other we see where the executive or the
male executives told you to stop posting
sexy pics I can't stop myself um so send
me t-rex uh I mean I have said it on the
show before and I'll say it again like
bebe Rexha in this house we stand - til
we die and I didn't really realize how
much I stand her until we saw her at the
t PG Awards where she did a private show
and we got to go to meet meet and she
was so nice and then we just watched her
perform and like you don't realize like
how many bangers she has she has had an
interesting career where it's like I
don't think she really sees albums she
just like has banger after banger after
banger and that's such a way to live you
know
yeah cardi B living banger - banger yeah
and that's so I'm call you mine with the
chainsmokers is so good also
Artur yes look she's really killing it I
love her and I love it
she is like such a defined personality
like I met her and I just remember being
like wow she's funny yeah look she's
bowls like you remember her I totally
agree she's cool yet I feel like she's
always in these situations where she's
like talking about how people like she
was saying no would dress her and it's
like what it's going on no because
that's what I'm saying she's in like a
unique spot where she's like a pop star
but like she and she's famous but she's
still technically like a developing
artist she won't even that she doesn't
have happened shopping she that like she
is in a weird spot yeah
so I guess well I'm tonight she's a
great success a hundred percent I feel
like she has a dream career and she gets
to do what she wants and she's the talk
of the town yeah and she was enough like
worried about keep releasing albums she
just like writes and releases and
collabs on songs that she likes but
apparently this music exact like it's
telling her she does need to worry
because she's too old to be sexy well if
I've learned anything from working in
the music industry for about two weeks
it's just that music executives they
don't know anything they don't know
anything no when it's like just the
people want what the people want and
artists who just like listen to their
followers so chance the rapper doesn't
even have a label you know what I mean
like those kinds of artists who just
listen to their audience and like give
the fans what they want like they're the
most successful ones not the ones who
listen to music executives we're like 95
years old and wouldn't know beep if it
dropped in their face I totally agree so
we support bebe Rexha we stand
I just got overcome by a wave of hunger
that is the worst that like started from
like my bellybutton
G for period uh finishing me to Margo
I'm now I finished last week cool well
finish well that's why I'm hungry I was
actually thinking this morning I'm
always hungry now either attributed to
the fact that I'm getting my period I
have my period or it's coming where I
just finished yeah or yeah and then
again it's you refuse so it's like um
maybe I just like will never not be
[ __ ] starving because I'm a woman and
I'm genetically predisposed to being fat
yeah but now because you're a woman
yeah beside my period and then period
makes me hungrier than a finish my
period we just finished it's probably
why I'm still hungry oh I hadn't afraid
I'm hungry now I'm getting it I
definitely feel hungry oh yay it's a
circle a little dishes psycho it's a two
weeks out of the year
out of the month per month that you're
just starving it's like how are you
supposed to fight that I think it's my
body type needs four weeks out of the
month definitely but I mean it's like
the week before and during and what am i
stood about that I said listen to my
body
I don't know counts I don't know but
these campers are out here and they're
hungry I'm actually I just got hit by
window job I made a wave of hunger - I'm
starving damn I got cheese yeah did you
have one of course that's lit yeah I
think that was a good thing to have like
when you were in school but maybe that's
because you were cool you had it and if
you weren't you did and if you didn't
have it you weren't cool
now it's the bummer sucks that bring out
all the Envy on the schoolyard I know
about Bobby right now cuz I have promise
from Margo and from the toast and I'd be
cool in the schoolyard they're the most
comfortable socks ever that is their
claim and honestly agreed they're
colorful bursting with color they have
even have a little colorful beyond them
comfortable so comfortable they're
designed with several comfort
innovations that help make them feel
better than any other kids suck ever
made interesting oh also donate a pair
of socks for every pair of PJ's know
that I love a sock packet that model oh
that's that's a good slogan we're all
about like rebranding the company's suck
the sock the sock and back really work
No so since they don't need a pair of
socks for every pair purchased you
should definitely get yourself some I
wear them almost every day when I need
to wear socks and I do find that having
like I used to just like buy socks so I
could I got about Mitzvahs you know what
I mean like I never cared about my socks
I totally agree I just heard who I stole
from my fellow campers yeah like I just
like would find socks on the street and
just like yes but once I kind of put
thought into my socks and like started
actually purchasing from like a like a
globally conscious brand I have found
that my feet smell a lot less I don't
know I'm not claiming that as a bombas
you know a pong table but I do find that
just like taking that and like maybe
wearing clean socks every now may
because the socks are clean and I know
the street well if you want some bomba
bomba visit bomba stomp / toast and get
20% off your first
that's Bo MBA s.com slash toast for
twenty twenty percent off your first
purchase that's bombas Bo and bas calm
slash toast 20% off Bo MBA s calm slash
test love it okay next up we've got a
little business because the media
landscape is shrinking as CBS and Viacom
merge what and all I can think is okay
so now CBS will you do something about
ten Jack I was singing the same thing
well CBS has not does not have a good
reputation the president being Les
Moonves so that's a step down and you
let me not forget that's movement let's
notice we not forget and also like the
Julie Chen of it all who lick wouldn't
step down I mean now like admittedly and
every episode of a barber says Julie
Chen notice when she used to just be Jen
she's like extra moon Viacom has like
the Dan Schneider like a stench CBS has
the les Moonves attention I think this
is a great merger with pedophiles and
music execs alike the Redstone family
media empire has been reunited after
more than a decade apart CBS and Viacom
announced they reach an agreement to
merge with Viacom shareholders receiving
nearly point-six CBS shares for each
Viacom share they own that values Viacom
at slightly less than twelve billion
dollars so what they own like just
Nickelodeon and Nickelodeon is genius
you know I saw a commercial for Ben was
watching a spongebob you Holly people
have like Netflix specials they the
collodion gave Jojo see what a special
and they're just like they taped her
concert like twelve billion dollars Joe
juicy was definitely worth five hundred
mellow that 100% today marks an
important day for CBS and Viacom as we
unite our complimentary assets and
capabilities and become one of only a
few companies with the breath with the
breath
morning resident you know the word
breads breads and depth of content to
and reach to shape the future of our
industry said Bob package president and
CEO of Viacom who will hold both titles
in the combined industry okay Bob like
you seem like a great guy who just like
writes fluff sentences for a living
didn't really mean anything like please
look into the Dan Schneider of it all
right ed shiner was fired but now he
liked him and his production company
like still produce a bunch of TV shows
he's gonna do the show he wanted one
thing like he's still there yeah and so
we're just gonna need you to look into
that Bob yeah because in the words of
Amanda sorry totally different reference
move on I was about to like really like
make mono maybe one of the worst jokes
in my career well now you know okay fine
anyways yeah I'm not interested in any
news for Viacom happy sad good bad
unlike what if it's happy and sad at the
same time hmm does that mean that like
Dan Schneider is getting his justice and
like maybe that means the cancellation
of a few shows
I would I would take it so yeah okay so
like come back to me but that's
interesting that's an interesting topic
when shows get cancelled looks like okay
happy and sad at the same time when
honey boo boo got canceled I was
literally devastated but at the same
time like good on TLC if we're doing the
right thing like when you have young
children you should have be dating a
pedophile mama June you know yeah
but they ended up like landing on their
feet on WE tv you know it's like
Bohemian Rhapsody I think is a good
example Bryan Singer it's like should
the movie suffer because the director is
an abuser yes
you think yeah what about the lighting
people they still get paid whether the
movie does well or not yeah the only
people if the movie got like if people
boycotted them would be the only people
who would be impacted are people who
like own a piece of the the movie which
it is literally only Bryan Singer yeah
no I mean there are a few other people
but those people who have that much to
lose or gain from the movie already have
so much like I do fine I don't feel for
them but like the movie really was
incredible it was good it was really
good I mean Ronny malas did still win
the Oscar and I think that was the most
important nomination that they needed to
win because he's so deserved it yeah I
just don't feel the way about Bohemian
Rhapsody the way they like everyone like
creeps our pants over it and I think
Rocket Man was better oh I guess the
Rocket Man was then I think Taron
Egerton Confessions of a Teenage no
[ __ ] I mean it's like weird like I
think they are in Edgerton whatever is a
curtain was just as good as rami malek
look where are the accolades agreed um I
I would agree with that
and I know it's gonna be a long long day
yeah but you just I guess because I went
into bohemian Roxy like really expecting
not to like because I thought it was
gonna be like a really serious film
about like Freddie Mercury and I just
thought it was gonna not be my cup of
tea but I came in and there was a movie
musical with every single song that I
didn't know that I knew had one girl um
that was exciting and because you went
into it with high expectations like oh
I'm gonna be obsessed with this movie
we're like yeah was that the pizza metal
story no that wasn't uh oh Viacom also
owns lifetime which is hard for so now
you're being impacted yeah because the
Lifetime movie Club um just safes lives
so yeah
saves lives time Sports News I just
really wanted to do again I didn't even
know it is business NFL is planning a
business partnership with jay-z's Roc
Nation the NFL is poised to announce a
sweeping business partnership with
jay-z's Roc Nation sources tell front
office sports the deal will give jay-z a
prominent role in the league's social
justice initiative with players as well
as creative input into the league's
Super Bowl halftime shows
oh I mean this seems just like the
perfect partnership like the NFL could
definitely use some some influence from
jay-z and Beyonce and then the
entertainment like it's really has been
slowly going in a downward spiral so
this is genius yeah this is genius I
wonder who he would position for the
halftime show well so Chloe and Halle
are there like protege is Beyonce and
jay-z so that's why I think when they
saying American the beautiful yeah maybe
now they'll do the star-spangled banner
I would love that meet you they were
they were really good we should be doing
the halftime show this year this is one
of my favorite things to speculate
because you know I always say I'm JLo
with a cameo from pitbull but then I
read a blind
did you see this one oh that is a reveal
that JLo is like trying so hard to get
Super Bowl halftime show the problem is
she doesn't have any hits she doesn't
have any hits from the last 10 years
yeah well I mean I wonder if enough time
has passed from Taylor Swift's dico
partnership
because for a very long time she
couldn't do the show because she was a
Pepsi I coke spokesperson and she hasn't
been the spokesperson for a while but
I'm sure there was some sort of
non-compete maybe now is the time she
has a new album I think any non-compete
for brands that big would be longer [ __ ]
yeah she has to do one day I know I
think she'll do it one day but like I
would imagine it would be like five
years a non-compete ariana grande who
Jonas Brothers oh I would love that you
do have a catalogue of a huge song she
do a throwback like for the like
2006-2007 maybe like miley - okay but
that wouldn't mean that that would be
good for us like now who watch the Super
Bowl yeah I like the Jonas Brothers idea
that's a good idea well make a short
lesson send it over to rock nation
yeah or Rihanna yeah but she has
literally no no music I know but maybe
she has some of them brewing she claims
she does and I don't know if she still
has that at one point she was a part of
rock nation so you get but in them it's
like JAMA where like she allegedly
hooked up with cheesy like there was the
elevators so I don't think that it's
just like I'm gonna be handing out
Rihanna
like opportunities Yeah right like
remember when and she said that jay-z
tried to murder
Rihanna yeah that's crazy crazy you know
who I think maybe would be like a
feature ah cuz I think he opened for
Beyonce dj khaled yeah but would be like
a feature like I'm someone else's
support actually could it be yeah she's
a lot of songs she has a lot of songs
but her career is very young and her
music is really like lyrically it's just
not Cable material you know ya know but
I think you need to be like a bona fide
star star for I would say 10 years for
the Superbowl at least so like Luke
Holmes oh my god are you Carrie
Underwood like give it to her she sings
every house she ever has every [ __ ]
no no
Oh
Sunday night okay me might have to head
to the airport so those were the past
five stories that you need to know we
are gonna be in Virginia Beach tonight
tickets available car with no job calm
and then tomorrow night Richmond
Virginia tickets also available at girls
no job calm very excited to see you all
thank you for listening to the morning
toast millennium morning show we go live
Monday through Friday 10:30 a.m. Eastern
Time on YouTube give this video a thumbs
up subscribe we're also available on
iTunes Spotify stitcher anywhere you can
listen to podcasts to subscribe over
there give us five stars follow us on
Instagram a car with a job at Jackie O
problems we love you see you tomorrow
with Ben stopper see ya bye
you